bom dia
uau bom é maíra pimentel pra vocês
maíra pimentel bastos santos na minha
certidão de nascimento
maíra pimentel bastos santos jane na
minha certidão de casamento maneira para
os amigos mais graça para os amigos mais
empolgados
tem também a maior nota que é do meu pai
tem mãe que os meus filhos tenho b é do
meu marido
tenho minha menina que era do meu vôo
nessas várias identidades maneira com um
único projeto de vida e aí é engraçado
lembrar e vindo pra cá ele se mexe me
veio quando tinha mais ou menos uns 14
anos o que é o término do ensino
fundamental 2 hoje a gente fez uma
atividade no colégio eu estava no peru
segundo nem sempre tudo em rede pública
o colégio federal no rio e atividade a
atividade da cápsula do tempo você quem
já fez essa atividade onde você escreve
uma carta para você mesmo guarda essa
carta para que daqui a 15 anos você
possa ler de novo pra descobrir aquilo
que você imaginava para a sua vida de
fato estava acontecendo
bom eu não tenho essa carta mas eu tenho
a memória dela e por mais criativa que
eu fosse naquela época a soma que eu
jamais imaginar que o meu projeto de
vida e me trazer para o palco aqui hoje
falar de um projeto de vida é falar de
negócio pra mim porque se a gente vai na
etimologia da palavra negócio ócio ela z
e negue é a negação
então o negócio é quando você nega o
lazer
você trabalha mas você trabalha muito
pra depois você tem o prazer de viver em
paz
quando resolvi fazer essa transição e
trabalhar na área social
trabalhar com impacto social é no início
de junho de 2000 2002 mais ou menos
eu não tinha idéia na verdade era com a
educação
se eu olho pro meu tempo de vida e
divido meu tempo de vida em três grandes
momentos
o último momento seja um terço da minha
vida foi quando tive a clareza do que eu
ia querer fazer pelo resto da minha vida
aqui é uma vida muito longa porque ainda
tenho muita coisa pra fazer
então realmente eu tenho que viver muito
tempo que eu quero destacar com isso
pontuando esse um terço da minha vida é
esse último terço
e foi exatamente nesse período que eu
descobri que eu não queria mais
trabalhar com comunicação e tecnologia
eu sou jornalista de formação
nunca trabalhei com um jornalista de
fato eu peguei o bonde web comercial no
brasil no final da década de 90 quando
me formei e trabalhando a de alguém que
lembre o cadê cadê ponto com.br
pois é o google ea e eu na verdade sair
da lógica do jornalismo tradicional foi
trabalhar com comunicação e tecnologia
até que no início de 2000 eu realmente
percebi que eu queria fazer alguma coisa
que fosse maior né
essa mania de querer fazer diferença mas
a marinha não na verdade a herança nem
minha mãe era educadora da rede
municipal estadual do rio baixada
fluminense e carioca de nova iguaçu
meu pai e técnico em informática e
ensino superior quando minha mãe
engravidou então acabou não concluindo o
ensino superior e os dois deixaram dois
grandes heranças a minha mãe à paixão
pelo público o público que é de todos na
o público é de ninguém que o meu pai me
deixou como herança a seguinte reflexão
que eu ouço desde que eu sou muito
pequenininha maíra
e aí o que você vai fazer com a única
vida que você tem cada ano passava ele
fazer essa mesma pergunta o que você vai
fazer com a única vida que você tem essa
ficha só caiu quando resolvi fazer essa
transição para trabalhar com impacto
social
e aí comecei a minha trajetória
trabalhando com institutos e fundações
empresariais e foi nesse momento que eu
me deparei com
a educação então eu digo que não fui eu
que escolhi a educação foi a educação
que me escolheu
mas na verdade a educação ea educação
pública em especial nunca deixou de
fazer parte da minha história
começando pela minha mãe passando por
tudo o que eu tive é de oportunidades
educativas na minha vida então o que eu
digo pra vocês é que hoje a maíra
pimentel aqui do palco é a maíra que é
resultado de todas as oportunidades que
teve e de todas as escolhas que eu fiz
fiz e faço diariamente
quando eu comecei no início do ano 2000
a trabalhar com institutos e fundações e
depois eu fui trabalhar no terceiro
setor
quando chegou mais ou menos em 2010 na
verdade 2008 eu e um grupo de amigos
montamos um grupo de estudos e pesquisa
e esse grupo de pesquisa acabou se
transformando na tamboro a tamboro é o
nosso negócio é com a tamboro que a
gente fica longe dos nossos filhos é com
a tambor que a gente fica longe da nossa
família enquanto um goleiro que eu abro
mão de estar com os meus amigos é 41
golo eu fico viajando o tempo inteiro
porque ser pioneiro eu volto mais uma
vez na tecnologia da palavra
neodi o pio é o primeiro é é você ser o
ator é você ser um lutador então ser
pioneiro quando a gente fala de educação
com inovação é de fato um grande lutador
é de gravar sem grande terreno xvii e
normas especialmente quando a gente fala
do brasil com a escala que o brasil tem
tamboro é uma palavra indígena que
significa para todos sem exceção
quando a gente criou a tamboro a gente
criou tamboro com um motivo único a
contribuir com o desenvolvimento do
brasil através de uma educação de
qualidade para todos sem exceção
como é que a gente quer e acredita que a
gente é capaz de fazer isso
trabalhando com as novas linguagens e
com as novas tecnologias têm uma
história que o encontro com uma amiga
essa semana e ela comentou o início de
carreira também jornalista recém
graduada ela foi trabalhar num
jornal de grande circulação aqui no
brasil
enfim ela é o time de um editor pelo
editor já bastante conhecido e
reconhecido
era um cara muito querido mas era super
rigoroso muito crítico então a galera
quando falava dele meio que temia né
o dia chamou na sala pra discutir uma
matéria e chegando lá depois de fazer
alguns comentários e inofensivo elogiar
alguns trechos quando eu estava saindo
da sala ele a chama de volta quando ela
virou ela percebeu que ele fez um ele
hesitou um pouco né
fez um na dúvida se falava falava e aí
ele complementou
só mais uma coisa nunca mas nunca mais
usei meia branca convocou assim não fica
legal foi a meia branca com rotas em não
foi o que ficou na memória dela
esse conselho é sob observação que ele
fez sobre ela e quando alguém faz uma
observação sobre você
o alerta send deixou claro para ela
naquele momento e deixa claro para mim
hoje também que quando a gente menos
estou prestando atenção às pessoas estão
observando a gente o tempo todo e ficar
atento ser autocrítico ser vigilante é
tomar cuidado com as coisas que você
fala com as atitudes que você tem e seja
na sua perspectiva pessoal com amigos e
família no mundo do trabalho isso é
super importante
só que a gente não aprende isso de forma
sistemática e gradual
a gente aprende isso na vida autocrítica
lhe uma crônica da fernanda torres que
ela publicou semana passada
fica a dica pra quem gosta de crônica o
título da crônica é eu e nessa prova que
a minha sensação é que ela inclusive
escreveu pra mim pra falar aqui hoje no
ted tem que agradecer se eu conhecesse
agradeceria pessoalmente ela discorre
sobre como ela fernanda torres uma atriz
madura reconhecida se olhou no vídeo ela
fazendo uma entrevista e aí ela começa a
se criticar e ela destaca dois pontos
que são pontos muito interessante
hilário não é um jeito dela conta
o ponto é que ela não terminou nenhuma
frase não terminar as frases com um
ponto
ela tem reticências estou com essa frase
olha pra cima e reticências
outro ponto que ela destaca na crônica é
que ela usa a palavra assim como vírgula
porque eu acho assim que a prisão do
cunha
assim e aí ela começa a se criticar
falando sobre essa muleta que é o uso do
assim como ela faz uma autocrítica como
essa né é anual já não tem idade que
fernando torres tem né mas se olhando se
criticando se reinventando ela está
destacando uma habilidade fundamental no
mundo contemporâneo que habilidade você
é capaz de se comunicar bem se comunicar
com clareza sem né confundir o seu
ouvinte
aí eu pergunto pra vocês a gente ensina
a gente desenvolve comunicação ou
comunicação é assim improviso quem nasce
como quem nasce comunicador chacrinha né
comunicador nato e sem sorte mas quem
não é assim não consegue chegar lá a
gente aprende na escola não a gente
aprende na universidade não mas a gente
aprende isso na vida de muitas vezes da
pior forma
hoje no brasil quando a gente olha isso
é uma questão só do brasil do mundo mas
eu vou localizar no brasil o modelo
educacional brasileiro é muito marcado
por uma industrialização tardia e pelo
regime militar
inspirado nessas linhas de fábrica né
a gente tem todos os saberes muitos
segmentados
então os saberes não se conectam dentro
da escola eu não tenho as disciplinas né
as matérias a matemática se relacionando
com a música e se relaciona com a língua
portuguesa que se relaciona com a
história e da mesma forma que não se
conectam dentro da própria escola e
saberes também não conseguem se conectar
com o mundo e aí fica o que acontece
dentro de uma instituição de ensino
versus o que acontece fora dos muros e
das salas de aula e esse é o grande
desafio
o que a gente tem porque se nós todos
colocamos na escola o centro da solução
de todos os problemas talvez ela não
seja a solução mas ela seja o centro da
questão
a gente está em pleno século 21
chegamos nele ea gente está de fato
preparado pra isso
de fato a gente tem conseguido
desenvolver todas as habilidades
necessárias nas crianças jovens e jovens
adultos e adultos que hoje estão
produzindo e ajudando a desenvolver esse
país saindo da lógica da escola e vim do
ensino superior aproveitando que a gente
está dentro de uma universidade
quando a gente olha para essa geração
que está aí que finalmente conseguiu
chegar lá vou aqui carinhosamente
chamada geração do fiéis que passou anos
e anos investindo tempo e energia
dedicação muitas vezes nem o sonho de
ter um diploma que não somos só desse
jovem é um sonho de toda uma família
porque muitas vezes esse jovem nessa
batalha vai ser o primeiro de uma
geração até conseguido concluir o ensino
básico ensino superior para ter um
diploma como se esse diploma fosse seu
passaporte pra esse jovem escolher o que
ele quisesse para a vida dele é que esse
mesmo jovem quando ele concluir é 12
anos do ensino básico quatro anos no
ensino superior
vou falar por mim 12 no ensino básico 4
superior mais de 18 meses de uma pós
graduação mas outros 18 meses de uma
outra pós graduação cursos de
especialização e até hoje eu não estou
preparada
até hoje eu continuo aprendendo
então a reflexão que foi o que eu deixo
aqui é será que de fato a gente está
conseguindo dar conta de desenvolver
tudo o que é necessário para que cada um
de nós para que cada indivíduo tem a
liberdade para escolher o que quiser pra
vida deles e falando de hoje dessa nova
geração dessa juventude contemporânea
quando a gente pensa em sucesso quando a
gente fala de sucesso
o parâmetro sucesso é ser feliz
vivendo aquilo que se gosta fazer hoje
eu posso dizer que eu tenho muito
sucesso na minha vida eu fico longe da
minha casa longe dos meus filhos sofreu
pra caramba com isso né abrir mão de
vários programas
outra crítica dos amigos da sua crítica
né da família não da família nuclear que
estaria segurando essa onda junto comigo
mas hoje isso tudo mas ainda assim eu me
acho uma pessoa de muito sucesso porque
o turno e acordo pensando no que eu mais
acredito e eu quero estar viva para ver
se um mundo de coisas incríveis que vão
acontecer na área de educação pensando
em renovação com educação
pensando na educação formal tô falando
de revisão de currículo
estou falando de revisão de habilidades
que precisam ser desenvolvidas tô
falando da gente da de verdade mais
chance para muitos mais pessoas serem
felizes fazendo aquilo que elas acham
que é bom para elas
na hora que eu falo de século 21 neder
mundo contemporâneo eu falo que o mundo
muda muito rápido
a juventude está mudando muito rápido e
o mundo do trabalho também muda muito
rápido
isso é o resultado de uma pesquisa que
foi feita pela the economist com 11
presidentes e ou gigantes empresas do
mundo
a pergunta central era quais são as
habilidades que você mais procura quando
você busca um jovem talento para seu
time
aqui eu vou destacar três delas as três
primeiras
eles buscam profissionais que sejam
capazes de resolver problemas a sentença
por maneira mas resolver o problema
basta estar vivo né se resolve um
problema atrás do outro todo dia só que
a gente está falando de resolver
problema complexo resolver o problema de
demanda pensamento crítico e raciocínio
lógico
a gente aprende isso de forma
estruturada não mas a boa notícia é que
dá pra aprender segunda profissionais
que saibam colaborar e trabalhar em
equipe
a gente aprende isso de forma
sistemática gradual não mas a boa
notícia
a gente pode ensinar isso a habilidade
de comunicação olha a crônica da
fernanda não aparecendo
em sintonia é isso comunicação se
comunicar não é algo nato né e também
não é algo que você improvisa tem
técnica tem procedimento de criatividade
para isso que é legal a gente também
pode ensinar
então hoje na hora que eu me pergunto se
a educação e pensando em educação de uma
forma muito ampla está dando conta de
desenvolver as nossas crianças e jovens
de uma forma plena
eu continuo com essa interrogação
esses jovens que têm a chance de agora
que estão com esse diploma irmãos e que
falta muito pouco para ele chegar onde
eles querem se a gente conseguir
construir sistemas que sejam universais
e que possam de forma continuada garante
essa formação e se pouco que falta a
gente vai conseguir fazer essa ponte
e aí sim todo esse esforço desses
últimos anos muitas vezes não só de um
jovem mas de toda uma família vai
começar a fazer sentido
o que eu quero destacar e acho que é uma
criança que eu carrego pra mim e fico
feliz em poder compartilhar com vocês é
que a aprendizagem aprender a ter
curiosidade com a vida é algo que também
se desenvolve e é um modo contínuo
ela é vital e ela só termina mesmo
quando a vida acaba obrigado